Abraham is the chief executive of the
British hospitality Association joins me
now Sophie who do you believe amber Rudd
all the Immigration Minister well mixed
messages like this are not helpful to
business we need certainty and we need
clarity so you cannot have the Home
Secretary trying to assure business that
there will be new cliff edge at the same
time as a minister responsible for
immigration saying that the end of free
movement will take place when we
separate from the European Union March
19 which is it going to be do you think
your members will take any comfort from
this report that the Home Secretary's
Commission's what businesses like ours
need to see and we're responsible for
four and a half million jobs in the
United Kingdom and we started our work
working with KPMG in our case over seven
months ago we provided the evidence to
the government in terms of the reliance
of our industry on EU Nationals and
workforce and all the implications and
in fact we went even further and
provided a solutions based plan but what
we want to see is a structured orderly
and timely approach to immigration let
me give you an example of an area where
we concerned you know we have messages
again mixed messages coming from the
government on the one hand government
and amboro today announce that the
migration Advisory Commission would be
responsible for providing evidence to
ensure that there would be political
decisions based on that evidence but at
the same time we're told that the
immigration white paper the immigration
bill is going to be published in 2018 so
again which is it that implies that the
immigration white paper is not going to
be based on the evidence which
government themselves have commissioned
today these sorts of mixed messages are
deeply concerning for the business
community so in other words you think
they've already made up their mind them
what they do maybe here well we hope not
and what we also hope is that the
migration Advisory Committee when they
come to do the evidence will not rely on
information which seems to be flawed
information such as the labor force
survey for example what we want to see
is assurance that the migration Advisory
Committee and the experts there will
engage directly with business to make
sure that they are generally having
real-world evidence with which the polls
can then make real-world decisions and
remind me how many what proportion of
the the workforce in the hospitality
sector are EU migrants so according to
the study that we did with KPMG months
ago seven months ago 700,000 about 24%
of our industry our EU nationals and I
want to also make mention one of the
thing if I may
there's a lot of reference at the moment
to skilled versus unskilled labour in
fact a lot of the people in our
workforce are being referred to as
unskilled labour we have to modernize
our approach in our terminology these
are individuals who are actually working
in the services industry they are
service people and this is their work
that actually keeps the UK economy
taking over and so you'd be looking
potentially I mean that's an enormous
number of people to try and replace I
mean it's so much evidence that a lot of
Brits wanted to do a lot of the jobs
that you migrants um and I was really in
the other day Preta Monge something like
1 in 50 job applicants only it's British
the rest come from overseas there's no
doubt that it's going to take time for
our industry to be able to make this
massive strategic adjustment in terms of
reducing the reliance on the EU
workforce that's going to require going
into schools working with the next
generation ensuring that vocational
education in this country comes to
mirror and balance the academic
education in this country ensuring that
young people can choose vocational paths
such as hospitality careers that takes
time all right of Abraham from the
British hospitality Association
appreciate you joining me thank you
thank you